with cloud shell editor you can easily
run code from your web browser and
deploy it to the cloud
in previous videos we learned how to
deploy hello world applications to cloud
run
and google kubernetes engine but what if
you want to extend your application to
use
other google cloud apis cloud shell
editor's cloud code integration makes it
easy
cloud code is a set of ide plugins that
help you stay productive when developing
cloud native applications
in particular cloud code has a cloud api
section
that helps you easily browse available
google cloud apis
enable them and add api client libraries
to your project
from the cloud vision api to the cloud
storage api
to the bigquery api the possibilities
are endless
let's take a look at how to integrate
the google cloud translate api
into a python flask web app first
visit ide.cloud.google.com to launch
cloud shell editor
select terminal new terminal to open a
new cloud shell terminal window
from here run git clone to clone the
sample code from github
then we'll open the sample application
as a new workspace
with the cloud shell workspace command
[Music]
you can see the list of files in the
explorer panel located on the left
side of the screen in the cloud shell
terminal window
change directories to the location of
the sample app
to run the sample app locally run the
following terminal commands
press command and click on the url
displayed to open your app
congratulations if you see this page
that means you successfully run the
hello world app locally
using cloud shell editor back in the
cloud shell terminal window
press control c to stop the local server
now let's set up credentials so that we
can authenticate google cloud api
requests for local development
in the cloud shell terminal window run
gcloud config set
project to set the google cloud project
you want to use
then run gcloud auth application
default login when prompted in the
terminal if you want to continue
type in y and press enter press command
and click the link displayed in the
terminal this opens a new browser tab
go ahead and authorize access to your
account
copy the authentication code displayed
and paste it into your terminal
[Music]
now let's go ahead and integrate a new
cloud api into our application
first click on the api icon on the left
side of your screen
this opens the api explorer where you
can browse the dozens of google cloud
apis for you to use
select the cloud translation api which
allows you to translate between more
than 100 languages
under enable api click enable api
under install client library select
python
let's copy the name of the translation
library and paste it into our
requirements.txt file
which lists out python libraries we need
for our app
now we can configure our python
environment using virtual m
and install dependencies using pip
now that the client library is installed
let's translate some text
open the web.py file to edit the python
code
first add a line at the top to import
the translation client library
next we're going to replace our existing
root directory code with the following
this translates the hello world text
into spanish
finally we'll run the updated
application with flask run
congratulations if you see this page
with the spanish text
you successfully integrated the cloud
translation api into your code
with just a couple of clicks we were
able to easily integrate a new google
cloud api into our project
want to try this out yourself check out
the interactive tutorial linked in the
description below
or by launching it from the cloud shell
editor welcome page
thanks for joining us for our exploring
cloud shell editor video series
make sure to subscribe to the channel
for more great videos
[Music]